what's your recommendation for an
employee that is late to work who
usually is late
but they're usually a good performer
so
being late
is unacceptable
and i i i tell this whenever i work with
a company and they start talking about
you know this guy's late for meetings
sometimes
i always tell him that i was in the
military for 20 years and i was
literally never late i was literally
never late one time yeah
think about that 20 years never late
never late
never late any time for anything
we would you know we would show up at
work in the morning so early that even
if the worst case scenario
my i got t-boned on the way to work i
would still be able to get insurance get
everything covered get a cab and still
show up and be an hour early
so
you should be you're right in the fact
that being on time is definitely very
very important
so people shouldn't be late so now
with this individual you got someone
that's showing up late for work you got
it like any other leadership challenge
what i would attack
is making sure they understand
why
why is it important some people never
make the connection as to why being on
time is important
so
you've got to explain to them why it's
important you got to explain to them
that's basic respect for other people's
time
that it's basic
operational readiness is to follow a
timeline that it's about being prepared
that it's about showing your reliability
and your professionalism
to to other people that you're working
with inside and outside of your company
and
even sun tzu
sun tzu and i i didn't say this during
the
during the
podcast that we did about sun tzu
and i can't believe i didn't say it
because i always believe in waking up
early and being early and sun tzu said
that he who is waiting on the
battlefield
is gonna win and who he was rushing late
to the battlefield is gonna lose well
that's the way your life is too and if
you're rushing and you things are
disorganized and you're running late
it's horrible
but if you wake up early and you show up
early and you're ready and you're
prepared and you're waiting on the
battlefield you're gonna win that's all
there is to it so those important things
that you have to explain to your
employee
that they so that they understand why
being late isn't unacceptable and why
being on time is the standard that needs
to be maintained
some people it's a horrible habit that
some people have of being late it's a
horrible habit
yeah you don't want to get into it it
just just unreliability
yeah um i was one of those people
i used to work in the nightclub um
in
here san diego downtown um for a while
too for like seven years
and unlike you i feel like i feel like i
don't know i don't i don't engage it or
another count them but
it feels like i was late
at the very least one minute late you
know you have a shift right and it
starts at whatever time either one
minute late or 10 minutes late i feel
like i was more i was late more times
than i was on time i feel like right so
my dad was always late i come from a
long line of late guys
so to speak but nonetheless um
but i was this guy i was the guy who's a
good performer i felt like i mean
according to my bosses and stuff and i
would you know i'd do well and
other than the time thing i was pretty
reliable um
very reliable in the nightclub industry
so
and i'd always justify it like man all
this time i would you know take to be
prepared to get there and find parking
and all this stuff um i could be doing
something else
in my life or whatever not necessarily
useful stuff but just something else why
do i have to work while i'm not working
you know like preparing for work i don't
know that was kind of my attitude as
long as i have good output as long as my
job is being done it's fine
so
when i stopped the you know when i was
done with the nightclub um industry
jade my brother would um he explained it
to me where
and the
the thing that i read that really kind
of hit me was
being late is a blatant disregard and a
blatant display of disrespect to the
person or people who are waiting for you
no doubt about their time which is time
is like
when you really think about it's the
most valuable thing you have so even if
you're talking about one minute or
you're talking about one hour
you are wasting that person's time if
you have a meeting or something right
you show up
five minutes late people are waiting for
you to start the meeting that's five
minutes gone where you know we still
have to go over that material so
we're gonna spend an extra five minutes
just because you're late because you
failed to prepare everyone else was
there on time
and you're the one doing it you know so
and then also i learned through uh
i want to say it was a book i read i
forget where but um where
one of the two
major the main things that ensure your
success or will get in the way of your
success is reliability being reliable so
and and
one day i went to the store right and my
wife sends me on this shopping spree she
says get this kind of tomatoes like
canned tomatoes but it was like this
specific kind you ever tried to go shop
for canned tomatoes bro there's like
this one and this one this one and i'm
like i'm just gonna either just grab one
anyone because i can't find this one or
i'm not gonna get them at all i'm just
gonna go home and be like you get the
tomatoes if you i don't even want
whatever it is you're making
so
i'm about i'm getting frustrated on the
inside like
like lo down the line of frustrating
things that i've told myself all the way
to the point
of
this isn't my job to do this it is my
job by the way but
this isn't my job i don't want tomatoes
why should i why am i even shopping
right now why are you telling this story
i'm making a point and in my opinion
it's a very important point
so
if i do that if i'm like you know what's
good i'm not getting the tomatoes or i'm
just going to go ahead and settle for
the wrong one i've demonstrated
and basically proclaimed that i'm
unreliable so why would anyone come to
me for anything who's to say i'm gonna
be reliable about it and sure you might
be reliable on some things but you've
demonstrated that you can and will be
unreliable under certain circumstances
and those circumstances are dictated by
by you so who knows really
you're not gonna get hired
no you're not you might not even be
somebody's friend
when you think about it or
husband
or whatever you know yeah definitely it
shows lack of being on time shows a
total disrespect for other people's time
and it shows a lack of reliability on
your part so these are the kind of
things you got to explain to your
subordinates or explain to this person
that's being constantly laid so that
they understand why you're telling them
that and then you they can then they can
improve and then you could
you know if the person's a good
performer generally that means they're a
type of person that care about how
they're perceived and doing a good job
so
let's get them to understand how being
late
affects
everybody else and affects their own
reputation as as a performer yeah so
it'll mean something to him
plus you'll be a come-through guy
everyone likes to come through guy the
guy who comes through
i'm sure they liked you for coming in on
time every single day for 20 years they
did they did